and so in our last video about the age
of apocalypse we discussed how the world
looks now with all of the new factions
and the new x-men related teams in
comparison to their normal counterparts
we discussed how Peter Parker how Reed
Richards Johnny Storm Black Panther
among some of the other more prominent
superheroes in the Marvel Universe had
actually died in the very early days of
the Age of Apocalypse and that those
individuals who were non mutants such as
Tony Stark and Donald Blake who never
became Thor we're either in hiding or
composed the last remnants of the human
government with the human High Council
who actually went as far as to hire
various mutants such as Jean Grey and
Wolverine to act as mercenaries within
the domain of Apocalypse and get them
information they wouldn't normally be
able to get on their own what we also
discuss was that due to Bishop claiming
that this reality isn't how things are
supposed to be that magneto was forming
a plan that involved I guess assembling
and pulling together various mutant
teams Nightcrawler would travel to the
mutant and human refugee camp of Avalon
to find destiny a blind woman who could
actually see into the future
gambit would lead a group called the
externals in order to travel into space
and locate the m'kraan crystal which is
the focal point of all realities in the
Marvel multiverse and Colossus would
travel alongside Kitty Pryde to the
Seattle core and rescue his sister
Ileana who had the ability to time
travel and travel into other dimensions
and so what we do now is we continue
with Nightcrawler now our expectation is
that Nightcrawler would be able to
teleport into Avalon to grab destiny and
to leave but model doesn't explain why
this doesn't happen and I would go as
far as to say that the security of
Avalon would either prevent this from
happening or the Nightcrawler doesn't
know exactly where destiny is but
regardless what we find is that
Nightcrawler gains passage aboard the
underground railroad system that's
managed by mystique to smuggle humans
out of North America in order to reach
the reach Avalon safely and once they
arrive Cain Marko mystique and
Nightcrawler
actually set out to find destiny herself
now once they locate her within Avalon
they inform destiny of Magneto's plan
which requires destiny to look into the
future and determine whether or not the
actions of magneto will be successful
furthermore before the group can
continue their planning they're attacked
by henchmen of Apocalypse which are led
by Deadpool who in this reality is
referred to as Deadman Wade now in the
Age of Apocalypse rather than Deadpool
becoming the comedic maniac that were
used to instead he's experienced massive
amounts of physical torture and is
homicidal and so what we find is that
while Deadman Wade and his group
initially attack Avalon that Wade's
actually turned on by one of the members
of his own team and when she tries to
kill him by cutting his throat his
healing factor kicks in and so this
results in Wade telling his team aid
that now he has to kill her because
individuals who were disloyal to
apocalypse are not allowed to live but
before Wade can actually deal the
killing blow to his teammate
Nightcrawler teleports in and that
actually teleports Wade's head off his
shoulders resulting in Deadman Wade's
death since this version appears to have
a limit to his healing factor in the
sense that he can't return or I guess he
can't heal if his head's removed and so
as a result what we find is that
Nightcrawler mystique and destiny
basically bring in the ranks of Deadman
Wade's team and they all set out to take
destiny back to Magneto now from here we
transition to gambit and his team of
externals now again with gambit having
never joined the x-men in the Age of
Apocalypse his affiliation with magneto
is more of a mutual dislike of
apocalypses rule rather than a desire to
actually become part of Magneto's team
the fact remains however that magneto
ascends gambit and his team of externals
into outer space
to capture the m'kraan crystal which
would allow them to look into other
dimensions and presumably collapse the
Age of Apocalypse dimension and on
itself the result is that once gambit
and his team arrive they actually find
themselves in a skirmish against the
Shiar Imperial Guard which is the
highest-ranking military guard that
actually protects the crystal itself
however with the help of the starjammers
which is a sort of rogue pirate group in
this reality that gambit and his team
are able to successfully gain access to
the inn cron crystal now once they gain
access to the crystal what we learn here
is that the m'kraan crystal is I guess
exists as a gateway to other dimensions
and is more of a multiversal
constructive what I mean by that is that
all universes have access to the m'kraan
crystal but should the crystal be
damaged in any one reality the
aftershocks will be felt across all
realities and so what we're told is that
when Legion went into the past and
killed Charles Xavier causing the Age of
Apocalypse to happen this resulted in
the crystal fragmenting leading to the
end of everything if the fracture is not
repaired and by everything I mean all
the universes all realities will be
destroyed and presumably they'll be
recreated in some form or fashion and so
in order to keep us from happening anti
in the Age of Apocalypse gambit and his
team actually secured a shard of the
m'kraan crystal and take it back to
earth to to magneto but what we also
learn here though is that one of gambits
own team members named guido is actually
an agent of apocalypse in disguise and
what he does is he sneaks a shard of the
m'kraan crystal as well and so the
result is that when gambit and his team
arrived back to earth that Guido
actually presents his shard of the
m'kraan crystal to apocalypse himself
and so from here we transition to the
last group which is the generation next
group led by Kitty Pryde and Colossus
and this portion of the stories actually
pretty straightforward here again the
group was assigned to enter the Seattle
Corps to rescue Illya Rasputin who has
the power to teleport through time but
when generation X actually sneaks into
the Seattle core what we learn is that
this place is quite literally Hell on
Earth while Marvel doesn't explicitly
tell us this the presumption is that
sugar man which is an agent of
apocalypse it seems to rule over the
Seattle core has routinely been sexually
assaulting Illyana Rasputin while she
was held prisoner there in addition to
this humans who exists within the
Seattle core are subject to the harshest
of conditions
some are killed indiscriminately and
others are forced to work to death and
what we find here though is that
Generation Next is successfully able to
locate ileana but the group is also
discovered by Sugarman
and so what happens is that the group
more or less initiates this kind of
civil war this kind of uprising within
the Seattle Court itself where they're
able to help humans begin fighting
against the various uh mutant overlords
but what ends up taking place here is
that in a fit of panic in an effort to
rescue his sister that Colossus actually
orders Kitty Pryde to bring Colossus and
Ilyana and Kitty Pryde herself back to
the surface and he ultimately leaves the
rest of Generation Next behind now as
the story comes to an end what we
actually find is that Colossus intends
to travel back into the past or I'm
sorry travel back to at the Seattle core
to rescue generation next and what we're
going to find here is that the story of
Nightcrawler and of gambit and of
Colossus that these are all going to
converge within the realm of this final
battle we're going to see things begin
to come to a conclusion and we see
exactly how all these events play out
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it and I will
catch you guys later peace